[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de la entrevista de france 24 en esta
oportunidad vamos a abordar un tema que
suele estar rodeado de tabúes de
silencios e incluso hasta prejuicios
hablamos de el sexo y el erotismo en la
vejez y por eso que nos acompaña a
ricardo iacub él es doctor en psicología
y también docente de psicología de la
tercera edad y de hesse en la
universidad de buenos aires de argentina
ricardo viajó muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
gracias por la invitación ricardo bueno
como un poco adelantaba en la
presentación de esta entrevista el
erotismo también la sexualidad de las
personas mayores pero está rodeada de
está bueno de silencios e incluso hasta
de rechazo se da como una suerte de
negación no de que son cuerpos
sexualizados y que gozan pareciera que
la sexualidad que el goce formarán parte
como de otra parte de la vida no como
explicas esto aquí lo atribuimos
en realidad es una tradición cultural en
el occidente bastante irregular pero que
en los últimos tiempos ha asociado la
vejez y con la perversión con el viejo
verde con la vieja loca es decir con
toda una serie de figuras asociadas a la
enfermedad ya que occidente durante
mucho tiempo concibió la sexualidad como
un medio para la procreación entonces
todo aquello que no iba hacia la
procreación y que se basaba en el coito
tenía tendría ser pensado como algo
patológico hoy la verdad es que lo que
sabemos es que esto no es para nada así
y que en alguna medida en los adultos
mayores nos muestran que no solamente
pueden disfrutar sino que también pueden
encontrar nuevas maneras de poder
acceder a estos goces qué bueno que
están mostrados en parte en estas
imágenes que a veces tienen que ver con
desde un abrazo un beso o un amigo toda
una serie de de figuras que se nombran
muy bien con el erotismo no más allá del
coito absolutamente ahora
su experiencia como doctor en psicología
y en particular en temas como hablamos
de la tercera edad como es la sexualidad
de la vejez de ricardo
bueno en realidad si pensamos en la
sexualidad ligada al coito vamos a ver
que disminuye la frecuencia básicamente
en primero el primer motivo no es el que
la gente en general supone si es
básicamente que muchos quedan viudos y
especialmente viudas las mujeres le
cuesta mucho más reanudar una pareja
sexual porque hay muchísimos más
prejuicios que recaen sobre las mujeres
que sobre los varones pero por otro lado
lo que vamos a ver es que la capacidad
para el coito para la masturbación se va
a ir reduciendo con el tiempo lo cual no
significa que tenga que terminar al
contrario cuando termina cuando hay una
dificultad concreta para la erección
para la estimulación femenina o para las
personas que perdieron el deseo siempre
lo que tenemos que pensar es que estamos
hablando de una patología es decir no
hay nada que explique por en sí misma la
longevidad tenga que terminar con la
sexualidad obviamente a todo esto le
tenemos que agregar que muchas personas
mayores
rechazan a otras personas mayores que la
sociedad como vos decías al inicio
rechaza estéticamente y nos parecen
raras las imágenes de las personas
mayores teniendo sexo nos parecen
incluso muchas veces hasta rechazan test
o nos parece que fuera gracioso o
ridículo entonces creo que todo este
conjunto de cuestiones hace que muchas
veces los mayores se intimiden a sí
mismos o sientan que lo que les pasa
interiormente no tiene lugar o no
debería tenerlo por eso es que muchas
veces los mayores cuando uno le habla
sobre estos temas
salvo que tenga mucha vergüenza en
realidad nos agradece mucho porque
porque están esperando que esto que
ellos sienten se convalide con un
discurso científico que les diga que
esto está bien lo que sienten y que
justamente si no sienten nada es porque
probablemente haya una depresión o hay
alguna patología que lo esté causando
tal cual ahora teniendo en cuenta lo que
han sido en otros estudios tu trabajo
con personas mayores que visión has
visto que tienen los propios mayores no
sobre su sexualidad sobre el goce y el
erotismo
en realidad las personas mayores tienen
una relación muy particular con su
propio cuerpo es decir lo desestiman y
más que nada las mujeres son las que
rechazan los cuerpos que no no se
asocian con los ideales de belleza que
permanentemente esta cultura nos está
insistiendo digamos de que que cada vez
que uno ve una película que tiene algo o
pornográfico o erótico no se presentan
cuerpos de personas mayores ni de
personas más gordas ni de personas que
no se asocian con el ideal de estético
de una época entonces todo esto lo que
lleva es que la persona mayor no se
sienta cómoda en este cuerpo cuando en
realidad es su cuerpo cuando en realidad
es un cuerpo que siente que puede gozar
y que puede hacer gozar a los otros en
los varones tenemos una situación
incluso más compleja es decir de muy
chico se asocia que nuestra masculinidad
tiene que ver con la capacidad eréctil y
con la capacidad de poder
a una mujer o de poder penetrar en
términos generales entonces cuando algo
de esto se pone se disminuye esta
capacidad eréctil por razones que son
propias de la edad no quiere decir que
termine sino que pueda disminuir que
puede haber más efectos del cansancio o
de limitaciones que puedan aparecer
al varón lo pone muy nervioso y esto
lleva a que muchas veces tomen
medicación que no está mal que la tomen
pero que requieren de la asistencia de
un médico o que muchas veces se retiren
de la sexualidad por miedo a la
vergüenza que pueden pasar si algo de
esto falla entonces creo que lo que nos
está mostrando es que esta sociedad a
diferencia de otras sociedades como
orientales donde muchas veces la figura
del tantra es decir de poder disfrutar
más allá del coito de poder acceder a
muchas otras voces la verdad está
bastante limitada y las personas mayores
son quizás los que más los resienten
alaba a ricardo precisamente recién
bueno de los casos en particular no de
cómo lo viven varones y como lo viven
las mujeres y entramos ahora en una
perspectiva de género que quería encarar
contigo no sobre este tema y vinculado a
esto entra también el tema de la soledad
no la viudez en las personas mayores
especialmente en las mujeres que tienen
un promedio de vida no mayor al de los
hombres que le diría ricardo a todas
esas señoras para que disfruten de su
sexualidad
bueno esto es una pregunta muy
importante porque porque sabemos que las
mujeres tienen muchas más limitaciones
como decíamos previamente que los
varones es un varón si no puede tener
una pareja probablemente vaya a de una
prostituta de una mujer mayor en esta
generación de mujeres mayores todavía es
muy limitado las aquellas que pueden
permitirse se pueden animar a poder
acceder a una sexualidad por plata o
unas o muchas veces incluso una
sexualidad que tenga que ver con un
deseo que no esté asociado al amor ni
una pareja a largo plazo es decir una
pareja ocasional entonces las mujeres
tienen muchas más dificultades como os
decía viven en general 7 años más que
los que los varones se casaron con
hombres mayores con lo cual las vemos
pasar muchas veces 10 15 a 20 años como
viudas yo muchas veces le hablo a la
mujer acerca de la importancia y lo
saludable que es la masturbación a pesar
de que toda nuestra cultura reciente
todavía rechaza por motivos que no
tienen nada que ver con la salud sino
más bien con
la búsqueda de la reproducción que hubo
en el siglo 19
cuestiones religiosas en realidad lo que
yo recomiendo muchas veces es por un
lado que se animen a probar parejas que
se animen a pensar que no hay una sola
pareja para toda la vida sino que puede
haber más parejas a lo largo del tiempo
pero también que se animen a probar su
cuerpo a disfrutar su cuerpo porque como
decía antes es saludable físicamente y
es saludable mentalmente ahora todas
estas ideas preconceptos no que decimos
que rodeaban al erotismo en la vejez a
los cuerpos de los mayores influyen en
la percepción que los propios adultos
mayores tienen de sus cuerpos de su gozo
y de su placer
si en términos generales hay como una
especie de percepción de que ya no
debería pasar más nada o que en realidad
a quién le voy a gustar con este cuerpo
os digo lo que se empieza a generar es
una dificultad en presentarse ante sí
mismos y ante los otros en sentir que
uno puede fallar
es decir hay muchas alarmas que se ponen
en juego y algunas más por condiciones
de género algunas por condiciones
personales por ejemplo se sabe que las
mujeres de clase media hay mucho más
preocupación estética que en las pruebas
que en las clases sociales más más bajas
pero también sabemos y esto quiero
destacarlo mucho cuando las las clases
más educadas son las que pueden percibir
sexualidad como como algo más abierto
más rico y creo que en este sentido los
invito a todos no importa el nivel
educativo que tenga una clase social que
tengan a poder animarse
a pensar que la sexualidad es mucho más
allá del coito es decir el coito es un
escenario obviamente tiene que ver con
algo muy rico que es la el orgasmo pero
el orgasmo puede llegar por otras vías y
hay que animarse y pensar que cualquier
forma deseo que no dañe a la otra
persona es válida entonces creo que en
este sentido la sexualidad es algo que
tenemos para disfrutar que tenemos para
conectarnos con nosotros mismos la
sexualidad está asociada con la
autoestima la sexualidad está asociada
con sentirnos amados sentirnos querido
sentirnos deseados y creo que estas son
necesidades del ser humano a lo largo de
toda su vida
vamos finalizando riccardo a ver estamos
hablando sobre prejuicios ideas no hay
mandatos culturales que pesan sobre
muchísimos mayores heterosexuales no
pero qué sucede respecto del colectivo
lg vete y riccardo que que sucede con
ellos qué particularidades tienen
bueno en realidad si desconocemos la
sexualidad más aún desconocemos la
sexualidad de las personas el eje de
temas o como queramos llamarlo y la
verdad es que hoy nos estamos
encontrando con que cada vez hay este
colectivo está aumentando porque porque
fue una con una generación terriblemente
condenada al escarnio a la vergüenza al
odio y muchas veces se animan con muchos
cuidados a poder mostrarse a salir del
closet como le llamamos y tiene mucho
miedo a la violencia que puede aparecer
por suerte en buenos aires- han
aparecido varios espacios para personas
mayores que pueden encontrarse que
pueden armar pareja que pueden que bueno
que pueden vivir su vida en conjunto y
que me parece que esto es importante
porque además tenemos que tener en
cuenta que este colectivo muchas veces
no tuvo al no tener hijos quizás tienen
más dificultades para los cuidados por
eso es que se está pensando y en este
momento en la argentina se está pensando
muy seriamente en espacios específicos
como por ejemplo residencias para
personas mayores lgv temas pero también
espacios de todo tipo para que puedan
congregar se puedan encontrar y puedan
disfrutar de la vida de la misma manera
que cualquier otra persona ricardo iacub
doctor en psicología muchísimas gracias
por estos minutos con france24 ha sido
un placer dialogar con usted
gracias a ustedes por favor audiencia
como siempre le invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
bien